ينضم الينا جون كلود روكي رئيس مجموعه
الصداقه الفرنسيه التركيه في مجلس الشيوخ
الفرنسي اهلا بك سيد جون كلود يعني
المفوضيه الاوروبيه ورئيستها ارسل
فوندرلين اعلنت بانه الاتحاد الاوروبي
يعتزم اقامه واستضافه مؤتمر للمانحين في
مطلع شهر مارس للمساعدات الدوليه لسوريا
وتركيا تقييمك بالبدايه لعمليه التعهد
بارسال المساعدات ووصولها حتى الساعه
هناك عمل
طوارئ كان ينبغي القيام به في بدايه
الاسبوع لمواجهه هذه الكارثه وقد ارسلت
فرنسا فرق البحث
والانقاذ وكذلك
الكلاب البوليسيه للمساعده في عمليه البحث
والاتحاد الاوروبي سوف يرسله ايضا 200 فرد
مع كلاب بوليسيه لهذا الغرض كما فرنسا
ارسلت مستشفى ميداني هذه هي المساعدات
مساعده الطوارئ الاوليه التي تم ارسالها
ونحن مذهولون لهول هذه الكارثه التي تسببت
بانهيار المباني
والكثير ونحن
نرسل وتعازين للرئيس اردوغان ولشعب التركي
ولاسر الضحايا وكذلك
ولقد
ابلغني نظير التركي رئيس مجموعه الصداقه
التركيه الفرنسيه وقد التقيت به في يوليو
في تركيا وهو بصحه جيده لانه في منطقه
تعرض للكثير من الاضرار اذا هذه هي
المساعدات الاوليه ثم نتمنى ان نتمكن من
تقديم المساعده الى تركيا وكذلك سوريا لكن
وضع سوريا اكثر تعقيدا
بسبب الاوضاع التي تسود هناك وينبغي
العبور من خلال او مم المتحده لتقديمها
المساعده وبالتالي فان فرنسا مستعده
للمساعده
هناك مساله مهمه جدا وهي مساله الدمار
الهائل الذي تسبب بهذا الز هذا يتطلب
ارسال الكثير من معدات البحث وهناك الكثير
من البلدان التي
تضررت من هذا الزلزال الذي تسبب بالاف
الضحايا ما دوركم السيد جون كلود كمجموعه
الصداقه الفرنسيه التركيه في ايصال هذه
المساعدات
اولا انا اتصلت مع سفير تركيا
فرنسا كما اتصلت ايضا مع السفير الفرنسي
في تركيا
ليساعدان على تقييم الاحتياجات ونحن ايضا
وقفنا دقيقه صمت في المجلس الشيوخ
حداد على الضحايا نحن من اجل صداقه بين
شعوب وعندما يحتاج الشعب للمساعده فدورنا
هو تقديم هذه المساعده اذا نحن
نؤثر ولا نقدم المساعده العينيه ولكن هناك
اتفاق في فرنسا
لتقديم المساعده الى المتضررين وهناك طبعا
شعور عام في فرنسا يؤكد على ضروره مساعد
الشعبين التركي والسوري
بما انك تحدثت عن الشعب السوري ايضا وقلت
بان الوضع اكثر تعقيدا هناك انتقاد الى حد
كبير لفرنسا ولغيرها من الدول الاوروبيه
والغرب بشكل عام بانه هناك هبه
لمساعده تركيا وارسال المساعدات فيما هناك
تقصير بما يخص سوريا هل
الجيوسياسه تلعب دورا حتى في
المصائب الكبرى
الامر صعب للغايه لانه عندما يكون لديك
دوله تسيطر على كامل التراب الوطني
تستطيعين ان تمر عبر الدوله لتقديم
المساعده اما بالنسبه لسوريا فان الدوله
لا تسيطر على كافه الاراضي فكيف يمكن
تقديم المساعده في المناطق التي لا تخضع
لسيطره في الحكومه وهذا لا يتحقق الا عبر
الامم المتحده وبالتالي فان المساعد
لسوريا معقده للغايه عكس تركيا التي يمكن
تقديم المساعده لها دون ايه عراقيل
همم تحدثت عن تطلعك لدور اكبر للامم
المتحده بالمساعده بايصال الاغاثه ان كان
لتركيا او لسوريا كيف ذلك عبر اي مسارات
اي ممرات
وخاصه بانه الان ثلاثه ايام على هذا
الزلزال هل تعولون على المرحله اللاحقه
ربما مرحله اعاده الاعمار
هذا
ولكن
الدوله يمكن ان تتحرك بسرعه اكبر من
الاتحاد الاوروبي والامم المتحده والمتحده
عباره عن اله بطيئه وفرنسا قررت ارسال فرق
البحث
والمساعده
وقد تم ذلك بسرعه ولكن عندما نلجا الى
الاتحاد الاوروبي او الامم المتحده فان
الامر صعب وهذا ينطبق على المساعده التي
تقدم الى تركيا وسوريا على حد سواء نعم
رئيس التركي تحدث عن انه فرق الانقاذ التي
وصلت الى تركيا هي من 60 دوله وتجاوز
عددها
21,000 كيف تقيمون هذه يعني هذه المساعده
الدوليه الكبيره
جيد ان تتضامن الدول فيما بينها واعتقد ان
هناك دول لديها امكانات اكثر من غيرها
وبالتالي ينبغي على هذه الدول ان تساهم في
جهود اعاده الاعمار وقبل ذلك ان تقدم
المساعده للبلد المتضرر اما بالنسبه
لمجموعه الصداقه الفرنسيه التركيه فهذه
المجموعه تركز على الشعوب والحكومات
موجوده وهي موجوده بطريقه شرعيه ولكن نحن
في اوروبا نحاول ان نقرب
الاعضاء المنتخبين في فرنسا مع نظرائهم
الاتراك ومن خلال هذه القناه نحاول ان
نؤثر على الاوضاع السائده شكرا جزيلا لك
اذا من باريس جون كلود روكي رئيس مجموعه
الصداقه الفرنسيه التركيه في مجلس الشيوخ
الفرنسي